so
the galadriel that we know from the
movie trilogy is magical and ethereal
but in the trailer you're like a warrior
we see you in the middle of everything
can you tell us a bit about where she is
at in this age
yeah she's dealing with a lot of grief a
lot of guilt um and a lot of
homesickness
she's
lost lots of people that she loves
and she has
this feeling within her that
evil is coming
um
but nobody else feels that so she's kind
of in a horror film to a degree she's
like believe me
something bad is coming
a lot of people are very excited about
this i'm sure expectations are high as
well do you feel this sense of i guess
responsibility to the fandom for this
show yeah absolutely
um
i am a fan of lots of things i'm like in
fandoms so i understand like where
that kind of
um
nervousness and skepticism comes from
because
you want things to be good you love
you love the material that lots of
things come from us but i think
particularly tolkien the loyalty to
token is amazing um
so i understand it and um but i also
i think the fans um also embrace lots of
different things there's huge like
variation in lots of the things that
have been made about tolkien's work like
the cartoon is very different to the
films and then we've got the hobbit
trilogy which kind of goes on diverges
from the books in lots of ways um yeah
so i'm just really excited for them to
see it as a fan myself
i've been asking the rest of the cast
like who from the original trilogy would
be
who they would like lose their mind to
know as a fan
of this show but i want to ask you about
kid blanchett like what would it be like
for you if you got a note from her
and she was like i love your performance
i love this show you're the best let's
have dinner every day for the rest of
our lives to be honest just to have my
name occasionally in the same sentence
as cate blanchett is more than i could
have like ever comprehended i don't know
if i'd i don't know if i'd survive that
to be honest she did that would be too
much but you're saying we should make
sure she doesn't
stay away
no she's i mean
she's a legend isn't she yeah yeah and
so you said you're in the fandom which i
100 appreciate what do you like geek out
over like you're here at the con what do
you want to see
i'm really excited about house of dragon
um what's really exciting about the sand
sandman
um
what else those are my like two tops
i'd say but there's so much here that i
didn't even know about as well that's
what's so great about comic-con um yeah
i don't know i'm always
i'm always open and ready for more
fantasy and sci-fi
yeah
now i want to ask you about working uh
with raz ahmed on hamlet
this must be
another sort of dream to be able to
bring into life what was that like uh
yeah
riz is an absolutely incredible um
artist you know he's a
he's a rapper
he's a director he's an actor and he's
just a really admirable person and it's
really exciting um
i love shakespeare and i think that's
also why i love tolkien you know there's
kind of a link between these kind of
rich rich worlds
and like a huge amount of
material yeah so i'm really excited very
honored
and finally you know since you're here
at the con you presented this to
everyone that's been waiting for it here
the excitement must have been through
the roof as as a group of you that we're
working on this together for you know a
couple years away from everything in the
whole world what was it like to be able
to share this experience together
it's so nice um
like you
you want this to give the fans an
escapism
um a magic and
it
it doesn't exist until they've seen it
so it's you know it's its final stage of
kind of
actually being in this world so i'm so
excited for them to see it
well i'm excited for all of you it looks
phenomenal thank you for the time thank
you cheers
you